i do want to talk about the the hype
house reality show
that will be on netflix
[Music]
when i heard this news i was so
excited how has filming been going
uh honestly it was a great time we uh we
rapped
oh you're done filming yeah we wrapped
like about two weeks ago
and um it was a great time
we all have thoroughly enjoyed it we got
to do
so much fun stuff because they would
like they would go and rent us little
places
and like okay we're gonna take you here
we're gonna have some fun and we're
gonna
do this we're gonna go shopping i'm like
wow like these guys are just setting it
all up for us like let's go let's do it
we're gonna go physical places we need
to go on shopping sprees
that's what i'm saying that's amazing
how long did you guys actually film for
about two months few months okay do you
feel like you've captured good stuff
oh yeah yeah oh yeah you guys have no
idea like people
are gonna underestimate it before it
comes out but it's
really gonna just hit everyone with a
bang that's awesome
what was the most challenging part about
having cameras
follow you around in that capacity where
it wasn't
your own self-filming well if you dealt
with an emotion
you like wanted to keep it to yourself a
lot like it was
it was something that was like i don't
know you
like drove yourself a little crazy but
you didn't know how to deal with your
emotions we didn't want to like
cry or break down or whatever you know
like because
everything that was going on was kind of
actually on camera so
that would be like you had this like
mental like
guard up sure
will we see your relationship with
charlie play out
on the show at all will we see your
songwriting process play out on the show
like what aspects of your life will
we see there's definitely going to be a
lot of uh
my storyline and just kind of like a lot
of that and how
how i've been getting into music and how
my life has been
changing i guess away from social media
it's
it's like i'm in a completely different
life than i was
six months ago and it's it's so
different it's so much busier
and like so much busier than i ever
thought it would be and
it really captures a lot of that what do
you hope that we learn
about you specifically as we watch this
show
well um i tell a lot about my childhood
like growing up in school my family like
what's my relationships like with my
my family my cousins my friends like my
roommates
like it's a lot of that it's like a
little insight on um
on me and who i am i guess okay is was
there anything
off limits when it came to the show not
not really no i mean
it wasn't like they had like cameras in
our house at night like
but like everything that um
that we shot like we didn't really hide
much no anything you were hesitant
to let them film i don't think i was
really hesitant with letting the film
anything
how have you learned to navigate the
haters and what is your message
to people when it comes to social media
social media is
a very hard thing it's a lot on on you
as a person um i've been able to
kind of find myself through social media
through
through music and those things and
that's helped me find myself and so now
i'm at a point where
i'm okay with myself and i don't really
care what anyone thinks but
back then it was a little bit harder so
just being able to
be who you are and then stand tall once
you're there
like that and have a little have a
little bit of confidence and
nothing else matters